okay go ahead
oh brother there was talk about you
running in 2020 you're not running in
2020 do you've said that many times yeah
he regret not running Oh Mike when I'm
watching the debates I was actually also
asked to be to moderate one to moderate
one of the debates and I didn't even
want to do that and when I thought I
shouldn't think yeah it was like he
should I'm watching the debates I'm like
so happy I'm not in any other did you
how did you did you seriously consider I
didn't I never did because it's the kind
of thing I think you feel in your your
gut your soul no you know if that is the
thing you're supposed to do in real life
care to explain the sound Oprah said
that Jesus would have to call her in
order for her to do it and I told her
Jesus called me what should I say but
you also have a very interesting take
you'd said if you were running you would
only focus on what you would do for the
country yeah I think opposed to all the
negative actually I think a lot of the
candidates make the biggest mistake
mistakes and certainly this happened in
the previous election you know there is
a there's a law natural law that says
what you give your attention to expands
so you should not talk about the other
die because you only empower your
opponents when you talk about them you
should talk about what you are going to
do and as little as possible not discuss
what the other guys are moving for it